hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are doing
my apartment hunting part two i went
apartment hunting in los angeles now
about
two weeks ago and i've released part one
of that video
last week so make sure you go check that
out if you haven't especially if you
want to know
what my wants needs budget things like
that were make sure you check that out
first and then come to this one
but this is part two and at the end of
this video i'll be
revealing to you all which apartment i
chose which is also why it's important
to go to part one because if it's in
part one now you don't know
which apartment it is and i'll link that
in the description box below
but yeah let's see the well first
apartment of this video but
fifth apartment total
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
so this apartment i'm gonna be looking
down at my laptop so this apartment was
as you saw a one bedroom
i think it's the only one bedroom i saw
to be honest with you
um but it was a one bedroom 645 square
feet
at 2485 per
month but because of a
deal that was going on um with rental
prices and i think it was like a one
month free situation
it really made the price of the
apartment
really 22.78 prorated 2 278
right away i loved this apartment i
loved how just
cute it was i think i think that's the
right
word for it it was just cute it was
small but also
still high functioning in terms of what
it had a
full kitchen a beautiful window where it
got in so much light hardwood floors
in the living room because that actually
is quite the non-negotiable for me
hardwood floors at least for the main
living area
i can deal with the carpet in the
bedroom but yes
main living area really needs hardwood
floors but yeah beautiful
bathroom and a nice solid bedroom
situation so there's really not many bad
things i have to say about it
other than and i think some of y'all may
roll your eyes at this
but i didn't like so it's cute
i didn't like how cookie cutter it was
i didn't really like there was nothing
special about it there's nothing special
about the unit about the building about
the location there's really
nothing special about any of it but at
the same time that also means there's
nothing
terrible about any of it really i also
didn't like
i don't know if you can see it in the
video but the
view of the window it
pointed directly to a shell gas station
and so that wasn't the most majestic of
things
but i could get over it but yeah i think
that's really how i felt i was like oh
okay
cool on to the next and so that is
really
my biggest con with it but overall i
think
that's a good thing there's nothing
terrible
popping out at you but i'm also the type
of person who likes to
i don't know feel something something
some kind of belonging some kind of
excitement and there really was nothing
here of that but in general it was a
perfectly nice
apartment so yeah let's go on and move
on to the next
[Music]
so
so i really liked this apartment this
apartment
just blew me away those finishes those
floors
that bathroom it's just blew me away so
this apartment was going for 2 124
it was a studio around 750 square
feet and i really enjoyed it
however um a very important
asterisk here that wouldn't be the
apartment i would live
in the apartment i would live in was
currently being
occupied and so i got to see
their only their oh the only available
unit they had in the entire building
and so that's that unit and so that's
so so disappointing for me because the
idea of
moving into a place that i have not
actively seen with my own eyes is
so hard for me to go through and so
in terms of the apartment i would be
living in there are a few things that i
don't like
such as the window i would have
in there is interior facing so basically
meaning that
it's facing the other portions of
the apartment building it's not facing
the direct
outdoor living and whatnot it's facing
kind of like a courtyard in some cases a
courtyard in some cases
it's actually other buildings and so
that
is extremely disappointing because if
you don't recall you remember watch part
one
if you don't recall natural light is
quite the big need for me especially
because i'm going to be
focusing on working from home and
everything like i
i need some sun i i need some sun but in
terms of the other things that
are on my needs slash wands list
i was very happy with the neighborhood
very happy with that specific
like block it was on it has a washer
dryer and unit and very updated finishes
as you saw in
the video provided there and so
overall it's knocked out a lot of things
the price is a bit over my budget um
but yeah overall it's knocked a lot of
things out and
note the price i'm giving you is for the
apartment i would occupy so the price
and the square footage i'm giving you
is for the one that i would actually
live in not the one that's in
the video and so just yeah make sure
just to know that but yes there's my
spiel and disappointment of that
apartment two and so now let's go on to
the next
[Music]
so this apartment to me was quite
breathtaking
i loved those floors those windows just
that wall full of window after window
after winter i just
loved that so much and it was so cool
because
the island you saw there in the kitchen
you could move it you could move it
around you could turn around if i wanted
it in my bedroom i would put it there
and so it was really cool just like
little
details and kinks like that i just loved
about this apartment it was one thousand
nine hundred and seven
dollars for 777 square feet
so fairly large and fairly reasonably
priced for the amount of space i'd be
getting
compared to other places and apartments
we've seen
and so i was really pleased with that
i think y'all know what i'm gonna talk
about next
and uh that's the bathroom
what was that
um i'm not very sure who designed
that or who's great idea that was but
did you
see so basically the layout was you have
a toilet here
a sink in the middle and then a
bath and then a shower here and
both have if i'm not mistaken both have
their own
doors but then you could see straight
through
each part if you were in any
region of the it was just a mess i i was
like
i fee i felt like i was in i don't even
know some type of
really old college dorm rooms yeah it
felt like
it was like a college dorm room type
situation it was not
cute at all and so i was not a fan of
that that layout and also just the
bathroom itself
i care about specifically bathroom and
kitchen
those that's really where you can see
the age of things
you know and that's really where this
was shown and that also kind of
surprised me because
the other parts of the building seemed
pretty well updated you saw the kitchen
the island
the floors things like that it's very
clean
and updated and not maybe not super
sleek or something but it's nice and
updated and renovated especially that
kitchen
and so i was just like did someone not
call the bathroom guy did he not show up
to the appointment to the party i don't
was he not invited like it was just not
a fun
scene but the building itself is also
very historical and
i liked that with seeing just these
really cool
mix and crannies of the building it had
a beautiful beautiful beautiful
this like library space library space on
the rooftop and it had a rooftop um
itself which the rooftop itself was fine
uh it was fine
but that library was truly truly like
majestic if only
i read no just kidding
but i also didn't like the street it was
on
i understand that with downtown things
are dirtier and messier and
sometimes like less kept up but
you typically know the neighborhoods
that are worse than others and this one
was part of the
not so maybe not the worst but the not
so great and so i didn't really
appreciate that either and i think y'all
who have
stuck with me have seen that location is
very big
with me and i so that was
disappointing to see but anyway
on to the next
[Music]
so this last apartment was priced at two
thousand four hundred and forty dollars
but because of a like again a move-in
deal that they were having the rent
would come out
to 2 315 per
month which to me to me
it was a bit overpriced now don't get me
wrong
i did enjoy this space it was 715 square
feet
and i liked that you saw a clear
separation
between the living area and the bedroom
area so i did appreciate that
but i don't know it just seemed a bit
over priced because
especially because this is the apartment
that wasn't downtown l.a it was about 10
minutes out it was around the arts
district
and so i'm not paying for the location
so what am i paying for you know what
i'm paying you know what it is that i'm
paying for
the facilities and services they have
let me
list this off for you real quick so
along with the
regular facilities you would expect of
any kind of luxury building
so rooftop pool gym community room
things like that
they also offered services i never heard
of before
for example you could have a personal
grocery shopper
who would get your groceries for you and
the only thing you would have to pay for
is the groceries the groceries that's
one
they had dog walkers also available on
demand they also had people
available to assemble help you move in
or actually put together things for you
or
if you have movers coming in or
assemblers coming in and things like
that you can have someone
come to your apartment from the building
come to your apartment and just
be there while they're doing that if you
aren't going to be home
and so they had all these really insane
like
perks that either cost no additional
money or
very few they had a very few costs
attached
to it and so that's that is i guess
where the
24 000 24 000 oh my god 2400 2300
comes from but before i bag on the price
and everything
i did really enjoyed that apartment and
so the biggest con with this place
really would be again i feel like i know
you guys are tired of me
saying this but the location it was
about 10 minutes removed and it was
basically right off the highway which i
didn't really like because
it didn't provide the most majestic
views
and everything and so i wasn't the
biggest fan of that
especially because all my life i've
never lived in like
the dead smack of things and so
i just really want for just a little bit
of time to just be
in the dead smack of things and so that
was the biggest con
for me that and i think it's the most
expensive
of the places i looked at total
even with the deal provided it's all all
things to
consider so which place did i choose
pause the video
put down in the comments which place you
think i chose
so i'll wait
okay which place did i choose
i chose apartment number two
of this video of this video so part
two apartment two now again
y'all know i'm upset that i don't
know the actual space that i'm living in
but the leasing manager was kind enough
to send me a video
of the actual space the actual apartment
um floor plan it was and so i was very
happy
about that so at the end of the day it
came down to
and you're gonna know what i'm gonna say
but location i
really loved the specific like block
the specific block it was on because the
location for
pretty much all i'd say six of the eight
places we talked about here
today and last week were all in downtown
l.a they're all
within just a matter of blocks and
minutes from each other
but some blocks were just better than
others and
all of that and so this one was just my
favorite block without a doubt and so
it came down to that and just the
overall
niceness and newness of the
unit itself and so i'm very excited to
be bringing you all along with me as i
move
i am moving let's see i am moving in
about a week
and a little under a week and a half
that's terrifying but
i'm also very excited to be bringing you
all along with me
on this journey with the apartment move
and
moving vlogs and empty apartment tours
desk setups regular apartment tours
and also with comes the move comes the
new job so bringing
you along with my first day of work and
day in the lives and
so i'm thinking i mean we'll see
but i'm thinking this is when i will
finally share with you all where i'll be
working and so look out for those videos
in the next
few weeks but i'm very excited that i'll
be
able to bring you all along with me i
hope you all
enjoyed this and please if you did
please please please
leave a like leave a comment helps me
out so much and i'll talk to you all
soon bye